oh my goodness this is weird
hi i'm destiny and this is leroy i'm
shaquita and this is my dog journey and
today we're going to be trying some dog
challenges that we've been seeing
circulating around the internet and tick
tock
i do use tick-tock i love making tick
tocks i think they're really fun
i haven't tried any challenges yet just
because i know leroy is not
interested in anything so i'm really
curious to see how she'll react to some
of these challenges
because sometimes she can just be stale
faced let's try
so here i am trying to wrap my head with
cling wrap so i can try the challenge of
putting peanut butter on my forehead so
i can
clip his nails it already feels dumb the
things we do
for our pets
[Music]
oh i really hope that there is saran
wrap
underneath because this felt like peanut
butter on skin contact
it's cold and it's wet okay so this is
leroy's brush he hates being brushed
so i'm hoping this peanut butter trick
will
no i'm not help okay okay
no yeah okay okay okay
it's working okay
is that weird this is weird huh this is
weird
okay okay
oh oh oh oh oh oh
you just don't know peanut butter
the struggle to open the blanket
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
and now we are just laying on the floor
cuddling
on the blanket
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
do
[Music]
so like children i guess dogs understand
that eggs are very very delicate
so we've got an egg
[Music]
okay
[Music]
not interested overall i had a lot of
fun
it was really fun to get silly with my
doggie and run around the house for a
little bit
okay definitely would try some of these
again this was really fun
and yeah i enjoyed it i don't know if
leroy did but i had fun
are you happy are you happy
she's gonna finish her frozen treat now
[Music]
you